my friend the other day told me that
he's been so on track with his fitness
goals that he's lost six pounds but me I
can't really say the same I've been
having a pretty hard time focusing and
keeping my anxieties away I actually
started meditating which's helped quite
a lot something else I actually started
doing is I just started designing I
realized I hadn't really done that in a
long time just designed something for
the fun of it a working in architecture
you don't always get to design cool
experiential spaces usually you're
working with a lot of constraints which
is good because the buildings have to
get built but here I'm just gonna put
all that aside and just create something
that's purely spatial and conceptual if
there's one emotion that we can all
relate to right now it's probably
isolation and maybe anxiety I'm gonna
create a simple path and a spatial
experience based on that one idea
basically I'm dividing the path into two
separate spaces and I'm also using a
little trick called compression and
release to create a sense of anxiety and
once the space opens up again to create
a bit of relief
first I'm starting off with some
diagrams to create what is called a
party party is the distillation of your
concept into a simple diagram it can be
a spatial concept or a material concept
or a combination of all of them
[Music]
this is how I'm thinking the
circulations going to work you enter
into this large space and as you
progress it gets narrower and narrower
on the other side do you enter into this
large space into this very narrow hall
and it opens up a little bit before you
exit
[Music]
I'm just sketching out what I want the
light conditions to be like the part
where the walls get pretty narrow is
gonna get pretty dark and the corners of
the room will be quite dark as well
so now I'm just sketching out what I
think the space is gonna feel like I
think I'll actually make this a curved
wall
[Music]
okay so now that I have a general idea
of what I want the space to feel like
I'm gonna try cutting a section through
here the wall will be somewhere around
here
and I'm making this wall low because I
want people on either side to be able to
see and hear each other and it's gonna
get taller as it gets closer to the
narrow point you have a roof and a
skylight that's bringing in a lot of
natural light and it's hitting this wall
I'm washing this entire space with light
this tall wall is also catching a lot of
that light and bringing it in and
actually I'm going to make this curve so
that you can get a nice even
distribution of light
[Music]
I've just made a quick RINO model based
on the diagrams I just made you can see
the plan here with the dividing wall in
the middle and that's what the section
of the space looks like I've decided to
put it on a slope so that the space can
get narrower in height as well as in
width we have this curved wall that's
catching this nice daylight and
diffusing it across the space and that's
what this tall wall is doing as well
so let me just walk you through the
space a little bit the dividing wall
gets taller and taller as the space gets
tighter and tighter once you pass the
narrow point the wall angles out and
gives you a little bit of sense of
relief the wall gets lower here so that
people can see and hear each other as
they're passing by let's try to take a
look from the other side and see what it
looks like
you have the tall dividing wall that's
capturing all this nice natural light
going in and you're going from a larger
space walking towards this narrow
opening so I pulled a couple renders
from the model and now I'm just gonna
bring them into Photoshop which is
actually my favorite part of the process
I've already applied the materials and
texture and the light conditions in the
model so there's not a ton of
post-processing that I have to do I'm
just gonna play around with the exposure
a little bit and got a person in for
scale
you should always add people in your
renders and sometimes I think I can make
a difference between a WoW
[Music]
if you liked this video please go and
give me a thumbs up if you have any
questions or suggestions on what I
should make next please drop me a
comment and finally I will be making
more videos so please subscribe
[Music]